[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN: Hey, I'm Alan.
Welcome to another
Talks at Google event.
We are here on stage with Melody
Yang from the "Gazillion Bubble
Show."
I just want to
dive right in here
and start talking about
the family history.
We were talking a second ago,
this is the Yang family show.
Get into family history,
tell me like how
you got here in New York.
MELODY YANG: Well, I mean,
it pretty much started
from my father and
his imagination.
When he was young, he was
always fascinated with bubbles
because one of his dad's friends
brought over a bubble toy.
And then, my dad, as he
grew up, he started--
my dad was very poor at the
time, and so he was working.
He was doing a lot of
street performances,
and so once he got
older, around 16, 17,
he started traveling around
Europe with my uncle.
And they were doing like
juggling acts, magic acts.
ALAN: So it wasn't bubbles yet.
MELODY YANG: It
wasn't bubbles yet,
but bubbles was always
in the back of his mind.
So he always was testing
different formulas
and trying to test out
different soaps and detergents
and whatever to find out a
formula where he can create,
you know, bubbles that are large
enough to do so many things,
to manipulate a lot better.
And then after that, yeah,
he came up with a performance
just with bubbles.
And it started off as like a
10-minute performance, and him
and my mom when they
met-- also my mom met him
when she was quite
young, and they
started to perform together.
And then they were
traveling on cruise ships.
They would do
street performances.
They'd work in nightclubs
and all over the place, all
over Europe first.
And then, once my brother
and myself were born,
my dad's like, hey, why don't
we just let them try it?
You know?
And so for us, it was
all fun and games.
It was play, and then he started
putting us into competitions
and talent shows.
ALAN: And how old were
you at this point?
MELODY YANG: I would
say I started at three.
I always say four, but three,
that's when I got on stage.
So four is when I
actually started,
I was able to create
tricks with my brother.
But three, I was
just put in a bubble.
Like I was the one
that walked on stage
and my brother would just
put me inside a bubble.
But that's when
me and my brother
started to perform pretty
much, and then from there,
we just started learning
different tricks
and it just grew more
and more over time.
You know?
ALAN: So you've
been here on stage--
or I guess, have you been
on this stage for 12 years?
You've been in New
York for 12 years.
MELODY YANG: We've been
in New York for 12 years.
I've only been here,
what, like seven years?
So seven, eight years, yeah.
ALAN: Your father
brought the show here?
MELODY YANG: My father
brought the show here.
So this full
production, it actually
was built in Korea at
the time, way before.
And then someone wanted to
bring the show here to New York.
I forgot who it was.
I was so young then.
So my dad wanted to test it out
and he brought the show here,
and we were only supposed
to run for about two weeks.
Now we've been running
here for about 12 years,
so it's been pretty good.
Pretty grateful.
ALAN: So now, obviously,
time has gone by.
You've been doing this-- how
long did you say, six years?
MELODY YANG: Here in New York,
yeah, about six, seven years.
ALAN: Do you have a title?
Do you call yourself like
the bubble connoisseur?
What do you call yourself?
MELODY YANG: I mean, I get
so many different names.
I get like bubble princess,
bubble queen, you know,
bubble master, but I would say
my dad's the bubble master.
I don't know, I just call
myself a bubble artist.
ALAN: I like that,
so you prefer artist?
MELODY YANG: Yeah,
artist is nice.
ALAN: So are there still
five people who perform?
I was looking on the website.
So I guess, who
still comes on stage?
Who rotates through?
MELODY YANG: We all perform.
So sometimes, we'll
have shows overseas.
Like my brother right now,
he's working in Orlando.
And my father, he's trying
to work into the theme park
business right now, so he's
working on something in Asia
with that stuff.
And my mother, she
kind of rotates with me
sometimes here and there.
She's like, oh, I'm
getting a little old,
I don't want to work anymore.
I'm like, mom, come on.
Like, you still look great.
You're fine.
And my uncle too.
So my uncle, he
just did the show,
he did a tour in China,
so that's interesting.
ALAN: So you guys have
basically franchised this out
to the family more or less?
I want to touch on
the world records.
You have 18?
The family has 18?
MELODY YANG: It's like mixed.
Some is my dad, some is my mom,
some is all of us together.
I only have three,
but it was broken.
ALAN: Know how many I have?
Zero.
MELODY YANG: OK,
I know, but still.
I mean, compared to my dad,
he just keeps breaking them
or he keeps inventing new ones.
You know?
So the ones that I have
are the most people
inside a bubble and the
world's largest bubble.
ALAN: So, the world's
largest bubble.
How big was the
world's largest bubble?
MELODY YANG: That
was 170 feet long.
ALAN: Wow.
And then you've
also got, I mean,
the family, between
all of you, you have--
elephant in a bubble
was one of my favorites.
MELODY YANG: My dad did that.
He did an elephant in a
bubble and PETA went crazy,
but the elephant
loved it, you know.
Like after my dad, he
changed the location,
he put the elephant
inside a bubble.
The elephant loved it and the
other elephants were coming.
They were trying to
like pop the bubbles.
Like they were
having a good time.
Nothing happened.
ALAN: So no elephants harmed
in the making of that record?
MELODY YANG: No, they were
actually really happy.
ALAN: So for the whole
family, the collection,
what's the record that
you're most proud of?
MELODY YANG: I would
say now, I would still
say the world's largest bubble.
ALAN: Not the
longest bubble wall?
MELODY YANG: Well
that is the one, yeah,
because we created it as a wall
instead of one huge bubble.
ALAN: How many people did
you have inside the most
people record bubble?
MELODY YANG: You know, we
actually had 200 people,
but they didn't count certain
people because they were kids.
So you have to be
like a certain height,
so that turned out
to be 181 people.
ALAN: That's ridiculous.
MELODY YANG: I know,
but hey, I'll take it.
ALAN: Are you
going to try again?
MELODY YANG: Why not?
Yeah.
I would like to.
We just need to get
everybody together,
but right now it's like
we're all all over the place.
ALAN: Well I think
you should try that.
We'll film that for you.
You're talking about
performing around the world.
Normally, I guess, how do
you travel with the show?
This is obviously sort
of a complicated set,
but when you and the
family get hired out
to go-- you said
Deni, your brother,
is in Orlando right now.
I know that you've
been to Orlando,
all over Europe you said.
How do you decide what goes
where and who does what show?
MELODY YANG: So
it really depends.
For me, I'm mostly
in New York because I
like to be in New
York, or it depends
like if we travel somewhere.
My brother-- when we
bring the show overseas,
then we would usually
have another set
of all of our bubble machines,
our bubble props, our lights,
our sound, our LED
screens, our LED trees.
So we have another
set here in the US
and we have another set in Asia.
Then we have another
set in Europe.
So once we confirm
a show overseas,
that's when we bring that
whole production there
and one of the
artists goes there.
And sometimes we'll rock
paper scissors who goes where.
I've actually done that once.
ALAN: So you said your dad's
working on something new.
Is it normally him that
comes up with new things,
or are you like in your
apartment here in New York
just like playing with
the bubble mixture trying
to do new things?
MELODY YANG: Well, it's
usually all of us together.
So if we're all here at
one time and if someone's
performing on stage,
we'll all come together
and we'll see what we
can do that's different.
Or we'll come across
certain things
as we're performing, because
all of our performances,
they're not exactly the same
sometimes because bubbles
are unpredictable.
We can manipulate it so much,
but still, if it bursts,
it bursts and we have to
come up with something
else on the spot.
But when we have those
kind of situations,
that's when we share our
ideas with each other.
Like recently, what did we do?
The bubble snowman, we
weren't doing that before.
And then Christmas was
coming, I was like,
I want to try to make a snowman,
so I made a bubble snowman.
And then my brother
started to do it
and he started to
get better at it.
And I'm like, OK, I
need to step up my game.
ALAN: So you have the sibling
rivalry still a little bit
there?
MELODY YANG: Yeah, sometimes.
ALAN: I think one of the
most interesting facts
about you guys in general--
I think it was Deni that told
me this when you guys came in
to perform at the
Google office, was
that you did the bubble design
for "SpongeBob SquarePants"
the musical.
MELODY YANG: Yeah.
ALAN: So that's true, yeah?
MELODY YANG: What do you
mean the bubble design?
We helped them
with their bubbles.
So they were having
bubble problems.
ALAN: People have
bubble problems?
MELODY YANG: Yes.
They had bubble problems,
my brother came in,
and their bubbles
weren't working.
They would appear and
disappear so quickly, and also
the positioning of where
they put their machines.
So my brother, being
the bubble consultant,
came in and told them
where to place it,
and also, we started to
provide them our solution.
And now, they are
having zero problems
and everything is great.
ALAN: I've seen the show and
the bubbles are quite good.
MELODY YANG: It's good?
All right.
ALAN: Yeah.
I enjoy it.
So you might get the impression
that, being a bubble show,
that it's all like
just for kids.
The audience, you see
the kids jumping around,
you see the photos
and everything.
Do you agree with that?
Do you think it's just for kids
or do you do it for the adults
as well?
MELODY YANG: I do
it for everyone
because I think every
single person in this world
still has a kid inside them.
So I think when
people see bubbles,
it touches that kid inside
them, no matter what.
And when I'm
performing on stage,
you don't see only the kids
reach out for the bubbles.
You see the parents, the
grandparents, and everyone.
Every time they do
it, they're smiling.
You know?
Bubbles just makes people happy,
and I think it's for everybody.
Yeah, it's for kids
because it's something
that you remember
when you're young
and it's something that's so
fascinating that you can't even
wrap your mind around,
because you're like, what
is this floating object?
It's not water.
It's not a solid, but
it's a water-based sphere.
And so I think that's
what always kept me going,
is to see people
captured in that moment.
ALAN: Right.
Obviously, you guys are here
at New World Stages in New York
City, and you can catch
ticket information,
more information about the show
at GazillionBubbleShow.com.
@gznbubbleshow on
Twitter and Instagram.
Follow them, like
them, share them.
It's wonderful.
Come see the show.
Thank you so much
for chatting with us.
MELODY YANG: Thank you.
ALAN: And we're going to show
some footage of the performance
you guys did for us.
MELODY YANG: Great.
ALAN: All right.
[MUSIC - BUNT FEAT.
EMMA CARN, "JOURNEY"]
[MUSIC - KLINGANDE, "JUBEL"]
[MUSIC - BUNT FEAT.
EMMA CARN, "JOURNEY"]
[MUSIC - THOMAS JACK &
JASMINE THOMPSON, "RISE UP"]
[MUSIC - SAM FELDT FEAT.
KIMBERLY ANNE, "SHOW ME LOVE"]
DENI YANG: All right.
Check one two.
Hey, how are you guys
enjoying the show so far?
Pretty good?
All right, well, before
we continue any further,
I would like to tell you guys
a little bit more about myself.
My name is Deni Yang.
I'm 27 years old and
I still blow bubbles.
I do own two Guinness
World Records.
One for the world's
largest bubble of 170 feet
in length, and the second one,
which was for the most people
inside of a soap bubble.
Any guesses of how many people?
Try 181.
So you can imagine how big
these bubbles are, right?
Now, unfortunately, I
can't do it here for you,
but I did bring one tiny
video clip to show everybody.
OK.
All right.
Here we go.
That's your cue.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So the record was actually
held in Beijing, China,
and the style of the bubble
itself was designed to be
like the Great Wall of China.
This is going to be the
video of the world's largest
bubble, which took nearly
two months of preparations
and almost 500 gallons
of bubble soap solution.
That's a lot of bubble soap.
The record was held by my entire
family, so as you can see,
my father, mother, sister,
and finally, my uncle.
And here we go.
Now, the bubble itself
had a surface area
of nearly 5,000 square
feet, and of course, it
took my entire family
of performers to do it.
Let's check it
out one last time.
And so, as of now, the current
record for the world's largest
bubble is still at 170 feet
in length, with a happy uncle.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
All right.
I really do.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
So for the next part
of the performance,
I would like to actually
introduce my sister,
so let's give her
a warm welcome.
Melody.
MELODY YANG: Hi, everyone.
Thanks, Deni.
Me and Deni actually--
well, you guys
are probably wondering
how the heck did we
get into this business, right?
I mean, me and my
brother, we've been
performing since I was
about three and him four.
Both our parents were
performers and they both
started out juggling,
magic acts, acrobats,
you guys name it.
And they were street
performers at first.
And then my father
came up with bubbles
and he was always fascinated
about bubbles just
like we are every single day.
Every time we see a bubble,
we stop to stare, right?
So from there, my dad
created a solution
where he could create a
show out of just bubbles.
And from there, me
and Deni came along,
and then he started to teach us
when we were little toddlers.
And we were performing
in circuses and galas
all over the world, all
over Europe especially.
DENI YANG: We would,
I guess, get punished
if we don't do good bubbles.
MELODY YANG: But I
mean, that's pretty
much about how we got into it.
So for this part, I do
want to show you guys
how to make your own
bubbles using just
your hands and bubble soap.
And I'm going to
need two volunteers.
DENI YANG: Big smiles.
MELODY YANG: Let's see.
All right, let's see.
I want to see who is sitting
nicely down in their seat, OK?
Let's see, I want
to get two people.
All right, big smiles.
Let's see over here.
Hm.
Do you want to come?
Yeah, come.
Let's go.
All right.
Can you step up on that?
You got it?
All right.
I'm going to need
one more person, OK?
All right, let's see.
You want to stay
right here for me?
Let's see, I see a boy in a
blue shirt right over there.
Yeah, a blue t-shirt.
Come on, buddy.
There we go.
Watch your step, OK?
It's a little slippery.
So I'm going to need
one of you to stand
here and one right over there.
Awesome.
What is your name?
OLIVIA: Olivia.
MELODY YANG: Olivia,
nice to meet you.
And what's your name?
EDDY: Eddy.
MELODY YANG: Eddy?
Nice to meet you guys.
So inside here, I have a
bowl of bubble solution.
What I'm trying to do is
I'm going to make a bubble
and I just want you guys to
copy exactly what I do, OK?
All right?
So watch me first.
All right, Olivia, watch this.
Looks pretty easy, right?
No?
All right, you guys try.
Let's see what you guys got.
Oh, not too bad.
OK.
I'm going to walk
you guys through it
step by step, all right?
So then when you guys go home,
you guys can do this at home.
Now he's like, I'm just
going to keep going.
All right, so first, Olivia,
you guys want to watch me?
Your hand has to be wet.
Otherwise, the bubble's
going to pop if it
touches anywhere that's dry.
Next, I'm going to
make an OK sign.
You guys see that?
I'm going to dip my hand
in all the way through.
OK?
And now I'm just going to flip
my wrist backwards a little bit
and blow a stream of air,
not too strong not too soft.
And this part is very important.
I'm going to close
that hole so that we
can capture the air inside.
Yeah?
Let's try it again, guys.
You want to get your
hand all the way in.
Let's make an OK sign.
Make an OK sign.
It's cold?
I know, but it's clean.
Oh, you got it.
Oh.
Make sure to close the hole, OK?
To capture the air.
All right, not bad.
Not bad.
All right, so
we're going to move
on to something really cool.
OK?
This time, we're going
to make smoke bubbles.
How does that sound?
Oh, nice.
Want to pass it to me?
And now you're going to
put it in your pocket
and take it home, OK?
All right, guys.
Now for the next part.
Olivia, can you dip both
your hands into the solution?
OLIVIA: Right now there's
a bubble on my hand.
MELODY YANG: There we go.
It's not there anymore.
All right.
Let's get soaked.
I know it's cold, but
don't worry about it.
We're going to hold
our hand out like this.
Perfect.
All right.
So when you guys
try this at home,
you're going to ask your
parents for a lot of money, OK?
Just joking.
Stay there.
Don't move.
So this is a water-based smoke.
It's nontoxic.
It's very light and
it's easy to control.
And now, Olivia, can you guys
connect the bubble together?
Or do that again.
Careful, OK?
I'm going to make
it first and I'll
let you know when to connect it.
Bubbles pop.
It's normal.
Hands are dry.
Have you guys ever wondered
why bubbles make you happy?
OLIVIA: Because they're
fun to play with?
MELODY YANG: Yeah.
They are fun to play
with, but it always
brings back memories,
especially for us older people.
I mean, I can do this forever.
All right, now let's connect it.
There we go.
Awesome, guys.
Perfect.
Let's give them a
round of applause.
Here, you want to
dry your hands out?
There we go.
Here's a towel.
Don't move, OK?
I got you guys something.
You want to hold onto this?
I'll grab that.
OK.
OLIVIA: Do we get to keep these?
MELODY YANG: You
keep those, just
make sure you don't drink them.
Thank you, guys.
Watch your step when
you go down, OK?
You were this way, right?
Watch the stairs.
Got it?
All right.
OK.
So for the next
part, I want to put
some people inside
a bubble, and I'm
going to need another volunteer.
So let's see here.
We've got someone over
there, over there.
Let's see.
I want to see big smiles.
Who's excited to
be here at Google?
Because I know I am.
Do you want to come?
Let's go.
All right.
Watch your step.
We're going to go
in the center here.
Tell me, what is your name?
OWEN: Owen.
MELODY YANG: Owen?
How old are you, Owen?
OWEN: Seven.
MELODY YANG: Seven years old?
Where are you from?
OWEN: New York.
MELODY YANG: From New York?
Very nice.
So you came all the way from
New York to see the show?
Oh, thanks.
Well, Owen, you're going
to stand right here.
You're going to look at
everyone and just smile, OK?
You don't have to do anything.
Stay right there.
Here we go.
How about that?
Let's do that one more time.
Awesome.
Owen, stay here, OK?
I'm going to put another
person in the bubble,
so I'm going to find
you a beautiful girl.
All right, let's see.
Girls?
Mhm.
Let's see here.
Do you want to come?
All right.
Here, let me help you, OK?
Let's stand right
next to Owen here.
Perfect.
What is your name?
RACHEL: Rachel.
MELODY YANG: What is it?
MELODY YANG: Rachel, right?
How old are you, Rachel?
RACHEL: Three.
MELODY YANG: Three years
old, and where are you from?
RACHEL: I'm four
and one quarter.
MELODY YANG: Oh, you're
four and one quarter.
Oh, you just forgot.
What?
RACHEL: Brooklyn.
MELODY YANG: You're
from Brooklyn.
All right, cool.
Brooklyn and New York.
Here we go, guys.
You ready?
Smile and don't move.
All right, let's do this.
Here we go.
One, two, and three.
That's not working.
OK.
Owen, turn your body this way.
OK?
This way.
And your head that way.
OK.
And don't move.
Stay still, OK?
And you too, Rachel,
your body this way
and your head that way.
OK, perfect.
It's a little awkward.
Let's stand a little
bit more closer.
OK, one more step.
All right.
A little bit more.
Don't move.
Stay right there.
You ready?
Here we go.
Let's all count
to three together.
One, two--
AUDIENCE: Three!
MELODY YANG: Oh,
I was just joking.
Again, one--
AUDIENCE: Two, three!
MELODY YANG: Let's
do a rainbow bubble.
Awesome, guys.
You did a wonderful job.
Let's give them a
round of applause.
All right.
And let's give it to her first.
Here we go.
You want to put one hand
under so it's easy to hold.
Here we go.
All right.
Thanks.
And this is for you.
Enjoy.
There we go.
Was there something wrong?
OWEN: It's a tiny one.
MELODY YANG: Oh, I'm sorry.
You like this one, right?
Well can you give everyone
another big smile?
Thank you so much.
You want to hold onto this too?
There we go.
Thank you, guys.
Watch your step, OK?
Here, let me help you.
There we go.
All right.
Well, me and Deni are
really happy to be here
at Google with you guys.
And I mean, we love
our job because we
get to make everybody smile.
It's not just kids.
It's not just parents.
It's literally everybody.
And it's something that we
need every day in this time,
is to remind ourself to just
live in the moment, you know?
So thank you, guys.
And we want to do one
last thing for everyone.
All right.
Where's Deni?
Let's do this together.
Let's get some music in here.
You guys ready?
Here we go.
[MUSIC - SANDER VAN DOOM, "ORI
TALI MA (LVNDSCAPE REMIX)"]
Where did he go?
Try not to pop it, guys.
Thank you guys so much.
I'll give you one.
High five.
Awesome.